hello this is precious Walker in this
video I'm going to teach you a really
cool math magic trick where you can
guess the digit that someone has crossed
out in a number here are the steps for
the trick you get an audience member and
you ask them to select a number and keep
that number secret so they can pick a
two-digit number they can pick a five
digit number they can pick any number
they want but they want they should keep
it secret
they shouldn't tell you what the number
is then what they're going to do is you
have them multiply the number by nine
they can do it on a calculator they can
do it on their phone whatever they want
they still don't tell you what the
result is
then what you have them do is they write
down the number and they're going to
cross out one of the digits of the
number so they can cross out any digit
of the number beside zero and you still
don't know what the number is or
anything like that
finally you tell them add up the
remaining digits of the number so
whatever digits of the number remain
they add up those digits and then they
tell you what the result is then comes
the cool part you're going to be able to
guess the digit that they've crossed out
and this is really cool because you
don't know which number they picked you
don't know anything else but you'll be
able to guess the digit they crossed out
so let's go through an example let's
imagine someone has picked a number
they've multiplied it by nine they've
crossed out a digit and they add up the
remaining numbers and they tell you that
this adds up to five so you're going to
do some mental calculation and you're
going to say alright the digit you
crossed out must have been four and
you're going to be correct so how does
this work well so whatever number they
tell you here's the trick that you need
to do what you want to do is you want to
add up to the next multiple of nine so
whatever X is you think of the next
highest multiple of nine and you add up
to it
so the multiples of nine are like 9 18
27 36 and so on so if they tell you the
sum of the numbers is 12
then you add up six to get to 18 which
is a multiple of nine or if they tell
you that the sum of their numbers is 20
then you add up 7 to get to 27 and those
will be the digits that they crossed out
so this trick works every time it's very
cool I provided a link for you to
explain how it works I hope you liked
the video please subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon catch me
on my blog bind your decisions on
Twitter at pressure Locker and you can
get my books listed on my website